so I'm going to talk I won't talk with
this title side too much you all know
the title we're working at MIT to try to
deliver so we have a site license for
Mathematica and we want students to use
Mathematica to program and learn
engineering so that's you know we're not
trying to do anything other than that we
are sort of forming a group a
cooperative I would call it it's not a
entity other than a cooperative of a
bunch of people there is a website code
seal org if you happen to be interested
in getting involved go to it there's a
little form give us your contact
information and how you'd like to get
involved there's opportunities for
students and professors we like the
acronym we think it stands for code
science engineering and learning you
know we think we're very clever
sometimes alright so for this talk um no
grumpy cat's no this is mmm this is like
a service for the professors who taught
me Mathematica who helped me get a PhD
who got me into a firm where I worked
for a few years who have established me
and I want to give back to those people
i have great love and admiration for the
professors that helped me and i want to
make sure they get to do the things that
they do well which is deliver awesome
curriculum so join participate if you
want but no grumpy cat's okay I forgot
to do this input thing dang alright so I
was supposed to do this ahead of time
yes so the two people who are leading
this many of you know my smiling friend
Craig Carter he's at MIT got a Wolfram
innovator award in 2012 big lover of
Mathematica and all things will firm and
then me I you know did a PhD in physics
did everything in Mathematica learned it
loved it and just went with it we right
now or have some educators at different
universities who are developing
curriculum and are very interested in
the design
of the interface that i'll show you
later in the talk and we are looking to
add names to this list so if you're
interested let me know and I will let
you know how to get involved we have
some actual designers so i am not a
designer by trade I don't know what I am
by trade but we have some people with
actual visual design skills and UX
skills helping tell us what is most
effective and what's not where's plenty
of room for input at this point we're
very rapidly developing right now so if
you have ideas let me know and I can
build them in we have some educational
researchers janet is at MIT in the
studies online education and stem
curriculum and it's a big part of what i
want to do i think educational
researchers need to be integrally
integrally involved in any kind of
education project they have skills that
we don't and then there's lots of
awesome students who have seen what
we're doing and so oh my gosh i want to
help make that thing into a thing and so
yeah if you have students and other
types of ambassador roles that you would
like to get people involved please let
me know all right so to the main point
sorry that side of the room I don't have
a laser pointer but I'm going to do it
over here so this is what we're building
this is the vision we have a teacher
sitting in the center they write
curriculum we all have Mathematica
notebooks with lots of awesome
curriculum there's a huge untapped
resource which is professors across the
world who have written mathematic and
notebooks with curriculum and what we
used to do is just send those notebooks
and get them back and that was great but
I think that we can do something a
little bit better so we have a
publication platform that takes a
notebook turns it into something Wow
yate turns it into something you know a
little bit different it's like a
notebook plus plus you send that to the
student who can be of any age they fill
it out complete the module send it back
because we've built this thing to
collect data on everything as well as
like so their interactions and
all of their coding attempts we're
collecting data on all that so we have
an automated analysis system that can
you know interpret everything that's
inside the notebook send you back a
report as a professor you also get back
the you know the actual content that the
student did so you can grade it yourself
if you want but we supplement it then
you can use that to improve your
curriculum but when we grade it we also
if you choose to give us permission we
share some anonymous data into an
educational data repository where
educational researchers can come in and
study your curriculum and how effective
how effective it is they can give that
information back to you through the
analysis system so if you have a cell
and you're like I'm not sure if this
one's super effective you know flag it
it goes out a researcher you know does
research ething sends you back a thing
and says you know fifty percent of your
students did better when they had this
so it does seem to be improving
something then you can use that to
improve your curriculum you can also
publish your curriculum if you choose
out onto the web so that all of the
world can have access to it and you know
we can collect data on usage from
students around the world who are using
your stuff outside of formal learning
situations and yeah so that's that's my
very era full direction that I've I'm
envisioning at this point so the
timeline because you know we all have
great ideas what is the actual timeline
phase one is in progress we're building
the notebook into notebook plus plus
system that's very actively being
developed it's been my side project all
summer long and I think it's getting
somewhere and I'll show you what it
looks like in a little bit phase 2 then
once we have this interface that we
think is actually effective and
well-designed then we're going to start
having people openly published
curriculum and then we'll create that
curriculum repository for the world to
access and stage 3 is then opening up
once a bunch of students have used your
curriculum opening up the data from it
so that educational researchers can come
in and give
you feedback and learn about what's
effective and what's not so first thing
we're going to look at is the curriculum
framework I would call it its notebook
to note book + + + before I show you the
actual framework I want to this flip
view in the notebook it's amazing but
sometimes when you click it it resizes
so it's going to be a little bit flashy
that's not on purpose so the main idea
is we have these lectures that we give
out to students we give them a notebook
we want them to do some work we want
them to take some notes and we want them
to have something that they understand
at the end so the interface that i'm
going to show has three main parts
there's lecture stuff that you've
provided there's a workbook and then
there's the lecture notes your content
goes in there student does work in there
and they end up building this nice
personalized textbook which is a
mathematica notebook with code and
annotations and whatever they've wanted
to add to it plus your stuff this is
kind of the the philosophy behind this
type of interface and the workflow that
we imagine although it's sort of
extensible and you don't have to use it
this way there's four modes of
interacting with this thing so if you
give a student content that you just
want them to read like you know read it
play with some code interact with a
manipulate that's one mode of
interaction so you have your text code
and interactives up there they can take
notes and do code explorations down in
the second pain and that's you know one
mode of interaction the next mode is you
say hey cool now I've shown you how to
do something try something for yourself
so you're asking them to try something
you give them a little challenge they
can sit down to the workbook and try to
work out what their solution is and they
have access to all the previous content
that's already been shown so we're
sequentially giving the lecture
materials like one slide at a time
essentially then so you've given them
some materials you've asked them to try
to solve something maybe they solved it
maybe they didn't either way right now
is the time
to intervene and say okay cool you tried
a solution I i also have a solution it's
not the only solution but here's how I
would have solved it so you they don't
need to be doing work you're just
wanting them to kind of watch what
you're doing they could open up the
workbook if they want to and work in it
but they don't have to they don't need
to be looking at previous materials but
they can and then you know of course we
want some kind of assessment so when you
give them a quiz I think they should
have access to a work area so they can
solve problems in Mathematica they
should have access to the previous
content we will add a flag if you want
there to be a quiz where they don't have
access to previous content for whatever
reason we can add that I think they
should have it but that's just a
personal philosophy and hopefully the
educational researchers will tell us
whether or not it's a good one yeah so
here's the kind of the overview of the
learning cycle you have them interact
with some stuff reading content then you
have them try something you know try to
solve something similar to what I just
showed you how to do then you show them
how you would have solved that thing
that you asked them to try then you quiz
them to make sure that you know they
give they learn something and then you
rinse and repeat with different contents
all right so now is the the big moment
hopefully everything works all right so
this is I have written a notebook and
built it into this interface right now
it looks like a notebook which is fine
with a little dock sell this is what you
send to the student so now I'm a student
interacting with the system i have this
notebook okay cool let's let's get
started with some content it's a very
powerful button that went up in the
upper left corner alright so now we have
the interface and i will kind of won't
go through all the details but here's
some example in the real world this is
curriculum that Craig has put together
over the years so Aria we want to learn
about the lennard-jones potential which
has to do with you know atoms inside of
a solid ok cool so we give them some
formula this is you know it's a textbook
fine
all right you know power of Mathematica
now you can show them something dynamic
that they can look at and say oh all
right interesting you can do some more
all right so let's look at what if what
if the you know energy of this particle
and a lennard-jones potential is high
then it's not just going to oscillate
right than the minimum it's going to
start doing some interesting things like
come really close to the center then
shoot back out and that's not a
symmetric process which is a nice little
thing so now you get to access all the
stuff that you know is really powerful
with Mathematica this is just a notebook
you know that anything you want to put
in there you can put in there so here
we're taking you know all of these notes
from the teacher sticking them into the
previous page all right now we want to
you know isn't isn't just about teaching
kids material sciences is about teaching
them of required litter literacy in
modern science which is programming so
now we have some programming going on so
all right so how do we actually do some
calculations now they can click and
evaluate the cells they can also give
them a little button because not
everybody when it's their first time
seeing Mathematica gets the whole shift
inter thing all right all right I'm
bored I want to skip it oh no of course
I can't because you have to complete all
of you have to evaluate all the cell's
fine okay all right this is calculations
calculations ooh pretty graph all right
so I want to play with this as a student
I'm going to send this down to my area
Oh or I need this to be a little bit
bigger all right now I can kind of play
with this interesting so what does it
look like out here oh that's kind of
cool all right awesome well I I kinda
liked what I did there I like I prefer
this so let me
save my scratch pad and say all right
and now I don't need this anymore
because I've saved a version of it so I
can clear my scratch pad bring that back
down I don't need it and now if I click
on this magic button that has everything
that was inside of the scratchpad so
we're storing everything when they're
attempting solutions when they're taking
notes they have the option to store that
in the system right as they're moving
through it at some point we'll make that
editable so that you can change this
kind of in place button that will launch
the notebook so then you can interact
with that notebook right inside the
system and save it back down into it you
can also say you know this is a notebook
so you can take notes so interesting
interesting things all right so now I'm
a student taking notes adding annotating
this notebook on the fly in a nice kind
of designed environment great so I'm
going to take all of my stuff shove it
on over into their including my notes
and that notebook so now this button
still has all of this content which is
also great for educational research if
you're studying programming education
you want to see their coding process you
want to see their attempts and figure
out if they're getting more
sophisticated in their coding techniques
alright so now it's a new mode all right
so now I need to try something
approximate the forest find the linear
approximation for the force I am NOT
going to try to do that on the fly
because I'm not so clever but alright so
I tried something for is definitely I
don't think that's the right answer but
alright I don't even know i'm going to i
tried something and we will add a
stopgap in there so they have to do some
interactions before they can progress
through the challenge all right so now i
try that thing now we can see the
teachers solution got some good feedback
yesterday that it might be nice to show
a pre
view of the whole solution and then walk
them through step by step but right now
it just goes through step by step so
this is you know I'm a professor and
this is what i want to do oh I have to
evaluate that cell before I can progress
I think that's a good thing but I
imagine students will go oh me so it's
something to force their attention to be
where you want it to be which is hey
here's some steps here's the things that
I tried don't just glance over this
thing and think that you have it at
least at least put your eyes in this
direction cool so then I'll save the
teacher solution all right and the quiz
it works right now I think there's a lot
fancier things we can do with some stuff
that's coming in mathematica but for now
you know I built some little multiple
choice quizzes will add some better
styling at some point all right force is
not the derivative with respect to time
oh yeah Chris respected distance that's
nice and then you can you know do short
answers we have a company out in Boston
who's very interested in working with
professors who want to do short answer s
short answer questions for science
content so you know explain this plane
your solution you can work with them and
they can build an automated system that
will you know kind of use a computer
augmentation to say you know they talked
about these three topics that you said
they should talk about but they didn't
really talk about this thing we may get
real-time interactivity at some point
right now I'm trying to build it so that
it's not dependent on the web because I
really want this to be published to the
web and have a Raspberry Pi version so
that somebody in a country who can only
get access to a raspberry pi or
something like that can still have
access to all this curriculum I'm a bit
idealistic like that so yeah all right
looks like I finished it let me move my
oh no I can't no I have to dang always
forcing me to do stuff
this stuff I must do all right submit
thanks for submitting the initial essen
do to do complete lesson alright so now
i'm a student and I've gone through this
whole lesson and what I have at the end
is the same thing that we used to you
know have them build but now it's a nice
automated process to build that up with
some sort of curated interaction they
have a notebook with all of the contents
that the teacher provided with the
annotations that they provide it with
the code that they were trying when they
were trying to solve these you know
problems alright cool I minutes left
good um yeah so this is kind of our
vision so here's that thing that I saved
and now I still have a notebook that has
all of my code very very useful this
would have been very nice if I were a
student there's also we're auto saving
the notebook so even if they're
forgetting to save it we're taking
autosave so that we can have a snapshot
of what they were doing at what time
while they work through this module oh
right so that is that's the big
interface notebook plus plus as I
thought so I really excited to hear
feedback about that I have like three
slides to talk about the publication
process because this is it's a pain
point for me when I've tried to use
other systems which is how do i get i'm
a teacher i have 13 years of content how
do i get it out there into the world i
don't want to use that stuff that you
wrote you know I know my students I know
my classroom I know my campus and you
know you should have the power to do
that and I think that this publication
system allows that to happen so you have
a standard Mathematica notebook standard
style sheet nothing fancy all you do is
add a few annotations so at the
beginning of the section you tell us if
you want them to be reading this content
if you want this to be a challenge that
they need to try if this is a quiz and
that's it you take the notebooks that
you have
you add a few words with a nice colon
colon to let our system know where they
are then you you know eventually will
come I always forget to do this input
thing all right eventually you come to
the website so this publication thing is
only on my system at some point we will
have a web form where you can come
upload it you can choose you know if you
want I want to publish this out to the
world and I want it to be built so that
it can run on a raspberry pi or I want
it to be built on a web version that's
down the road probably because you know
the mathematic front ends amazing and
I'm not afraid to use it so I'm going to
stick with the desktop first and then
move to the web because we can all
download files from the internet that's
fine um yeah you know you you have
access to whether this is going to get
published into the curriculum platform
where we'll also try to build you know
maybe a knowledge graph of science if we
get enough curriculum and you know you
may or may not use this to study it for
educational research you can you know
choose your own licenses all this stuff
that you want to do and all the stuff
that I want to do with my stuff oh cool
yeah so that's that's my spiel